140余年続く日本橋うなぎやの女将です
自分の肩書で苦しんだことってありませんか
私はこんな容姿で皆さんから
カミさんぽいねー似合ってるね偏食だねってよく言われてきました
言われています
でもそれが次第に自分へらしさの表現の制限になっていったんです
その制限が外れた今私に起こったことを今日はお話しいたします
こう見えて私や日本橋の生まれではありません
生まれは新潟で両氏は公務員
農家の祖父母に育てられました
田舎の閉塞的な雰囲気がとっても嫌でオープンな場を求めて外に飛び出し
まず飛び出しました
前職は
dice k のティーチャーなんです
まず役所
忙しい毎日にやりがい感じてたんですけれども
4日公以外所のない根無し草な感覚にとらわれています
そこで3.11の震災を機に
自分のためだけに生きることに疑問を感じて結婚を意識したまたま主人に出会って
子の家日本橋に行ってまいりました
大きくとまた驚かれます
なにそのキャップあってそしてなんかよかなかったの
サイト後女将さんになることに入って
実は私はそのギャップにこそ運命を感じたんですね
といいますのも
可愛い保育園ながらん
私あの保育園の頃日おじいちゃん子でしておじいちゃんと一緒に時代劇を見るのがもう
日課だったんです強制的に
そこで出てきたのが3
御箸とか江戸の女将さんだったんです
がっかりあそこで描かれていた女将さんっていうのはとっても生き生きしていて私の中
でこう
理想の女性=女将さん
不思議な保育園生だったんですね
私
あれっ
嫁ぐと決まった時にはあもし自分が女将さんになるんだったらこんな世界を作りたい
っていうはっきりとしたイメージを持っていました
嫁いだ私は張り切ります
やってやっと見つけた居場所ですそれに運命も感じちゃいました
私は頑張りました
私が日本橋の女将さんとして大切にしていたのはパッと見てわかる日本らしさを残す
ことです
いったん外に出たものだからこそ
なんか日本っていうステレオタイプなものにとても価値というか憧れ活動を感じていた
んですね
が例えばな匂いしたかと言いますと着物です
私あの小津安二郎の映画が大好きなんです
どういうイメージをかみさんだったらまあ喜ばれるのかしらと思って
監督の映画を何度も何度も見ました
そこで出てくる女優さんの着物の柄だとか
2巻とかあと仕草っていうのを徹底的にコピーして真似して自分に適用させたんです
そして出来上がったのが
今この姿です
[拍手]
この神自分でやっているんです
こうやったらね喜ばれるかなと思って試してみました
こうした努力は実を結び皆様から面白がっていただいてメディアにたくさん取り上げ
られました
そしてそれを見た方がお店にいらしてくださって私に合って喜んでくださったんです
私はすっかり役になりました
そしてハマっていくんです
このサイクル
一見成功サイクルに見えませんか
目標を決めて努力して達成して言って評価されて
これが実は花だったんです
頑張れば頑張るほど成果の出る世界
頑張らなきゃ成果の出ないん
私は課題にはプチ当たりました
気づかせてくれたのはライフステージの変化です
私には今9ヶ月の娘がいます
かわいい
娘は私にとってほとっても大切な存在です
娘が産まれたとき私は何とかして今まで作り上げてきた女将さんと子育てと両立したい
と強く願いました
その方がかっこいいですよね
子育ても頑張って輝くキラキラした女将さん
またなんか本の出版依頼が来るかもしれない
思えました
1ヶ月娘が1か月の土地も店に連れて行ったり
お三味線の稽古を再開したり
日本橋のイベントです
これはまだ1ヶ月の時に
ちゃんと女将さんしてますでしょ
こういうことを続けていったんです
してい
その努力の結果
無理でしたーー
全然無理スター全くできませんでした
やりたいと思っていたことが
できない段取りしていたことが
うまく回らない
この葛藤の中ですごい自分苦しんだんです
こうありたいと思っていて頑張ってきた自分で着てきた自分なんだからまだまだやれば
できるんじゃないか
皆さんの期待に応えて女将さんってゆーぞーずっと提供していけるんじゃないかって
思っていました
それと同時に
大事な娘のことだけ見ていたい
誰も私に期待しないでー
見ないで見ないで私たち一人にしてっていう自分とでとても苦しんだんです
それはあ
こっちにあの神さんでありたい自分と
子育てだけしていたい自分と常に引っ張り合っているパワーゲームです
私はとっても疲れました
な時
ある問いに出会ったんです
それがこちらです
ずっと皆さんも考えてみてください
が浮かんできますか
会社員
web デザイン
ここでいう本業とは必ずしも職業ではありません
さんが対峙している
自分が対1にしている在り方なんです
俺を問われたとき
答えがここまで出てるのに
躊躇して言えない自分がいました
皆さんも考え続けてみてください
今岡んだ答え
それしてるだけで本当に満たされますか
俺をしているだけで歌されること
私の中で出てきたい答えが
かあさんがあったんです
認めたくありませんでしたこの答えが出てきたとき
いいじゃんお母さんでてみんなからよく言われたんですがとっても抵抗があったんです
今までの私は女将さんとして
何か社会に価値を提供してお客様に喜んで頂いてそれで自分の価値を確かめてきました
この人どうですか
初回に何提供してるんだろう
自分で受け入れられなかったんですただただ娘と遊んであーたのし買ったねちょうだね
があるね
なのでありえないって
分で受け入れることができませんでした
でも
いままでやってきた考え方でやってきてうまくいかない現実があるんだから何か
ちょっとものの見方変えてみよう
私の本業お母さんだっ
早期潔く受け止めることにしたんで
そしたら
私のある変化が起こりました
これがすごい大事でした
ただ私はお母さんなんだ自分らしさに気がついて
その時間を満たしていただけで
ところがあった
あってリラックスしたんです
例えば皆さんもすごい疲れた時にお風呂に入ってばーって開くすしますでしょ
そういったような感覚です
今まで着込んでいた
クロエがあっ
右去った感じでした
私がしていたのは単純なことです
ただ夜寝ている娘の顔を見て
[音楽]
ただこれだけ
親バカなんです
たったこれだけのことなんですけど
今までしてこなかったんです
この時間をとっただけで私の心はいらいらから回答
混乱から解放され
とってもリラックスしました
そんな気リラックスした私にまた不思議なことが起こり始めるんです
それが
今日この場このトープの歯がまさにそのいい例だんです
よしこうやって皆様にお話をしたり
新しいことにチャレンジしたりやったことのないこんなマイクつけてみたりとか大好き
なんですね
今までだったらそういうことは自分から手を伸ばしてチャンスをつかみに行っていまし
た
でも今回は
全く違ったんです
ただただ自分のやりたいことに気がついて
その時間を持って行っただけで
いうか
私私女将さんと見ないでと決めた瞬間に
このオファーのメールをいただきました
のことってあるんだと思う
いきました
例えば何かがないと思ってそれをが欲しいから手に入れる
獲得しにいくっていう方法は巷にもたくさんあります
でも今あるものに気づいただけで未来はどうやらやってくるようなんです
なことでびっくりしていた私をさらに驚かせることがやっていきます
それが
周りからの助けです
お願いをして助けてもらうのって誰でもありますよね
場合は
ここに遠くに登壇し用途
持った瞬間からベストなタイミングでベストな助けがやってきました
例えば
プロフィール写真
皆さんてプロフィール写真を持ちいらっしゃいます
持ってなくてあーどうしようと思ったんです
あ同省の署名女神でも出しちゃうかなってと思ったその瞬間に
友人が facebook でプロフィール写真の撮影を始めていたんです
これが
の人にお願いしよう
にとってもらいました
このトークの内容
私
こそこのように本業お母さんと決めても育児も寄付しちゃいまして
自分で何考えているのか何を伝えたいのかを待った混乱していたんです
実はもう前日までこれ撮った検証と思ってまして
あの子供がいるからほら待つ女が風式ましたじゃあ逃げられるでしょ
そんな時にたまたま
[音楽]
友人からメールが来るんですよ
その後どうですかもし私でよければお手伝いしましょうかっ
なんじゃこれはと思います
後私は自分が好きなことをやって心を満たしているだけなのに
チャンスや
周りからのヘルプが来るんだ自分で頑張らなくていいんだ
はとっても不思議な体験でした
不思議な体験
映画
のこと応援してくれるような気がしたんです
肩書きや理想の像があるときにそれに自分を合わせようとするのは
自然な感情だと思います
でもときにそれは
自分の自由を制限するブレーキにもなり得ます
本当の自分らしさに気付い
雪の自分で勝手に思い込んでる制限を外してその人らしくはれた時に未来あチャンスは
向こうから勝手にやってくると
ます
本業に気づいた私は
これからただただ未来からやってくるものを安心して受け取りながら
新しい女将さんをやっていくと思います
ここにいらっしゃる皆さんの中で自分で勝手に思い込んだ制限から自分を解放し
自由にその人らしくあれる人が一人でも増えたら
この世界はもっと
リラックスした
クリエイティブなものになると信じています
今日はありがとうございます
[拍手]